in superhero movies a bad guy always
loses rice well black panther wakanda
forever flips the script on that a bit
here's how Neymar comes away with a
victory of sorts warning spoilers ahead
Namor is a significantly different
origin story and black panther wakanda
forever than he does in the comics one
of his many MCU names is kukul Khan
which is also the name of a feathered
serpent guard in Mesoamerican mythology
they called him
instead of rolling Atlantis he rules
over talukan a hybrid of Atlantis from
the comics and aztecness to Lalo Khan
the level of the afterlife reserved for
those who died water-related death with
these changes Marvel could avoid
confusion with the DC Universe at
Atlantis and had a chance to create a
rich backstory for yet another culture
that like wakanda was founded by people
of color and flourished into a highly
Advanced Society in an interview the Los
Angeles Times actor Tano dueta talked
about what it meant to him to be playing
a character in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe that has darker skin he said
this is the first superhero with an
indigenous background a meso-american
background it's a brown skinned guy his
ancient culture is in his roots and he
speaks like me we are making history I
told them let's do something to be proud
of in the comics Neymar is the son of an
English Explorer and Princess fan of
Atlantis he has none of the massive
American Origins that he has in the
movie but one element from the comics
that persists is Neymar's shifting
allegiances depending on what best suits
his ends at the end of black panther
forever sure he defeats Neymar but takes
Mercy on him offering to let him yield
he does so and the two fly back to their
Warriors together demonstrating the
truce later Neymar reveals to namora
that he believes the surface world will
come for wakanda to take their vibranium
and when that happens wakanda will look
to talukan as an ally I need to know
before
an enemy this is basically what Neymar
wanted from the beginning the king
originally went to war with wakanda
because they refused to turn over Riri
Williams a young scientist who built the
vibranium detecting apparatus nor they
agreed to go to war with him against the
surface world yet this truth signifies
that they may be willing to align with
talukan in the future should they ever
find themselves under attack Time
Magazine has stated that Neymar will be
returning though they seem to be basing
this more in the position that Neymar
finds himself in at the end of the movie
rather than any official announcement
from Marvel it definitely does seem like
we'll be seeing more of the character
and that would be as opportunistic as
his Comics counterparts Neymar made his
comics debut in 1939 in Motion Picture
Funny's weekly issue 1. in his first
appearance Neymar viciously attacks a
crew of a salvage vessel trying to bring
up lost treasure this is followed by
Neymar's mother telling him the story of
why they don't trust surface dwellers
some of them attacked Atlantis and
killed many of their people so even in
his brutal first appearance Neymar's
actions can be justified as defending
his Nation May more often switched his
size between heroes and villains and
never really settles down as one or the
other in 1964's X-Men Issue 6 agnito
tries to get Neymar to join his
Brotherhood of evil mutants but Neymar
quickly becomes disenchanted with
magneso's leadership and turns on him in
dark Avengers issue 8 Neymar joins the
X-Men but even in his time as a member
of a superhero team Namor is morally
ambiguous in Avengers vs X-Men issue 8
May more floods wakanda during a
conflict with the Avengers interference
of direct orders from Cyclops that scene
was clearly an inspiration for one of
Neymar's more malicious acts in wakanda
Forever it's hard to call the mcu's
version of Neymar good or evil either it
does some extreme things but in the name
of protecting his Nation from a
legitimate threat from the people of the
surface his actions put him on a similar
level of moral ambiguity to some other
MCU villains like ghost or killmonger
they all have Justified ends from their
perspective but do immoral things to
achieve them with the movie leaving the
door open for Neymar to return it's
possible he'll return as an anti-hero
rather than a full-on antagonist
foreign